30 jahre wiedervereinigung und wovon
singen die deutschen
[Musik]
1990 spielte deutsche musik in diesem
land noch keine große rolle
nur 18 der 100 erfolgreichsten alben
waren deutschsprachig
heute sind es jedes jahr rund 70
das verhältnis der deutschen zu ihrem
land hat sich verändert sind die
deutschen bei sich angekommen
was heißt das für ein land mit dieser
geschichte
[Musik]
top nation deutschland
wie lebt es sich da
ich glaube ich habe mich immer schon
zerrissen gefühlt zwischen allen orten
die ängste sie noch viel konkreter
geworden klar man muss stellung beziehen
oder steht automatisch auf der falschen
seite
acht musiker innen sprechen zur lage der
nation immer zwei haben wir gegenüber
gestellt
den anfang machen musiker und aktivist
mal leg und sammy amara von den broilers
die gnade der geburt sie uns vereint
gefahren hängt schlaff und schwer wie
blei sommermärchen ist vorbei der nebel
ist nicht zu erkennen chemtrails und
dummheit und was wäre wenn aus diesem
schuss mal etwas kriegt das hässlich ist
ein hässlicher riecht wenn das alles
nicht so bitter wäre
[Musik]
wie gestalten sich gewiss regiert würde
es mich nicht was willst du jetzt sehen
[Musik]
liebe zu der verschlossenen tür
im moment bin ich dabei oder seit langem
wenn ich dabei fürs neue album zu
schreiben aber das geht runter wie ein
stück holz also ich kann irgendwie nicht
schon wieder über dieselben themen
schreiben sieht immer noch aktuell sind
ich bin zwischen ohnmacht und gut an
sammy amara wurde 1979 geboren unter
bundeskanzler helmut schmidt
aufgewachsen ist er in düsseldorf da
lebt er auch heute noch mit 13 gründete
er mit seinem kumpel eine band auf der
dann die broilers wurden
[Musik]
geradlinig authentisch musik die heute
stadien füllt
hitler gruß an die schlägertrupps waren
bürger jubeln wenn die nazis die straßen
ziehen hassreden ja für ihn abends in
den tagesthemen
das brennen heute und bettina predigt
krank gewesen v-leute npd verstrickungen
die endlos gehen wer eines zum
fondsstart gelegt fand ich mit meinen
schneebrett das uns brd free zu lange
weggesehen jetzt sitzen sie im bundestag
wie viel muss noch geschehen keinen
schritt weiter wir schlagen alarm kauf
der vorschrift muss egal buchbar
themen wie rassismus sind durch corona
nicht weg im gegenteil
themen wie flucht und migration sind
dadurch nicht weg im gegenteil viele
menschen geht es gerade jetzt in der
kroner zeit noch viel geschissen
und deswegen war es mir wichtig jetzt
nochmal mit no pasaran sozusagen noch
mal ein zeichen zu setzen klar gegen
rassismus male wurde 1983 geboren
da war helmut kohl bundeskanzler
aufgewachsen in heidelberg lebt er jetzt
in berlin 2000 gründete er mit seinem
bruder harry potter die glücklichen
revolutionäre jetzt ist er solo
unterwegs die botschaft ist geblieben
ich war vorher kleiner punker glaubt mit
11 12 gegen die punker zeitlos dann
haben wir auch angefangen musik zu
machen an die das schlagzeuger und ich
und das war alles süß und das war alles
unschuldiger mann einfach löcher in der
hose und kleiner iro lederjacke dann
haben wir aber skinheads für uns
entdeckt traditionelles skinheads und
das ist halt das was einfach nicht jeder
weiß zu der zeit anfang der 90er waren
skinheads absolut gleichgesetzt mit
nazis da haben die wohnheime gebrannt so
legen etc und zu dieser zeit haben wir
beschlossen wir werden traditionelle
antirassistische skinheads und herren
redding und ziehen uns die klamotten an
da war aber alarm da war alarm weil mein
vater war das augenarzt er wurde darauf
angesprochen was ist denn mit ihrem sohn
los ist der zieht sich jetzt an wie die
nazis die da vor dem ärztehaus rumhängen
dass man wirklich nazis ja das muss da
musst du ein bisschen erklären
[Musik]
die musik du bist du sonst bekannt
das haben wir in berlin gedreht in einer
alten verlassenen halle die typen waren
groß waren ziemlich groß und sonnen ss
mandl
er wiegt so viel wie ich ja und da hat
der typ den an gehabt das hat sich so
beschissen an gefühlt wenn dir dann
durchs treppenhaus gerannt sind wenn die
vor ihr standen diese vorstellung dass
so was wieder möglich ist es ist da
kriegt man eine gänsehaut also absolut
grausam
manchmal sitze ich da und sagt ich kann
nicht mehr ich hab keinen bock mehr
drauf dann stelle ich mir die frage auch
wenn es ein bisschen pathetisch klingt
was wäre wenn wohin würde ich dann
fliegen können wo könnte ich überhaupt
denn was würde passieren
wann würde ich verstehen dass es zu
gefährlich werden und dann wenn ich mir
das wieder vor augen führen weil sich
faktisch muss das kommentieren ich muss
meinen teil dazu beitragen versuchen
alles zu tun was ich tun kann damit ich
mir am ende sagen ist nicht sagen muss
ich habe einfach die hände im schoß
gelegt das möchte nämlich nicht ich sehe
mich ja eigentlich als musiker und
aktivist gleichzeitig ich nutze die
musik um irgendwie auch eine message
rüberzubringen um leute wachzurütteln um
leute auf themen aufmerksam zu machen um
leute auch zu pushen zu supporten zu
einem bauern
[Musik]
es kann verschiedene sachen anders
ausdrücken in verschiedenen deutschen
und den französisch ich versuche gerade
immer mehr auch wenn der musik beides zu
kombinieren also ich fühle mich in
beiden sprachen zu hause logischerweise
sind ja beide ist meine mutter und vater
sprachen wie auch immer man es nennen
will
aber wie passt jetzt musik angeht war
für mich immer französisch einfacher
weil du halt viel mehr spielen konnte
ist mein wort anders und auch teilweise
neue wörter fast kreieren das passiert
in frankreich viel mehr und in
deutschland hat sich da die letzte zeit
also in der musik viel getan so da kann
man ist es jetzt ein bisschen lockerer
geworden auch das finde ich ganz geil
weil da man mit der sprache einfach viel
mehr machen kannst
[Musik]
was wir mit einer revolte damals auch
schon bewusst irgendwann waren wir waren
natürlich sehr stark in der subkultur
haben uns bewegt und haben auch dort
gespielt auf demos nach wie vor bis zum
ende aber irgendwie haben auch bewusst
den schritt gemacht zu sagen wir gehen
auch mehr in die kommerziellen clubs auf
größere festivals weil wir eben auch
mehr leute erreichen wollen und des
musik super tool kommt der wahlverlierer
verdreht
die lava kinder verträge alles klar war
nichts wird sich ändern solange wir nun
aber manchmal sind sie auch songs die
auch hoffnung geben manchmal songs die
einfach wütend sind aber ich habe
einfach so viel freude und hoffnung in
mir
lasst es mich irgendwie trotzdem nicht
runterziehen
und jetzt hip hop duo zugezogen maskulin
und sängerin ela
[Musik]
vor ein paar jahren war ich noch
ziemlich unsicher in denen ich gemacht
habe und auch in meinem charakter
aber heute habe ich mich einfach
entschieden ok meine stimme ist dunkel
die songs die ich immer geschrieben habt
sind immer so er aus dem mehl acony
entstanden und das was ich mache das
eigentlich eher richtung schwarz als
schwarz weiß grau und wenn man sich
entscheidet dann entscheidet man sich
auch für eine sache und ich habe mich
für die farbe entschieden
elif oder 1992 geboren unter
bundeskanzler helmut kohl
sie wuchs in moabit auf und wohnt auch
heute in berlin mit 16 nahm sie an einer
castingshow teil
vier jahre später erschien ihr erstes
album
aus gefühligen pub ist heute urbaner
sound geworden
[Musik]
auftritt brandenburger tor ausgebuht
aber gut bezahlt fühlt sich geil an
zensiert das team wir sind so weit
gekommen und das letzte jahrzehnt
schluck vom treibsand an dem tag als in
den letzten paar kauft nicht bei
zugezogen aufnahmen näherten sich zwei
cops in eisenach wartung gezückt ein
camper aus dem raum der berkel jahre
vorteil des jahres ist er ist dick auf
dem bahnhof geblendet von den lichtern
fühlte mich wie ivan drago wahren
paradies doch eigentlich so sarrazin
jetzt machte er die ortsvorsteher von
juden gehen und von kopftuchmädchen
gegen auf eins in die charts damit war
über meine mitmenschen alles gesagt die
maske war gefallen es folgten zehn jahre
verblödung einer endlosen spirale aus
skandalen und empörung wir werden die
letzten 10 jahre 10 10 ärgerliche jahre
vor zehn jahren der der große tabubruch
das unsagbare da ging's los mit mit
sarrazin deutschland schafft sich ab und
vor allem in dem riesen erfolg den das
buch auch hatte wo man sich noch dachte
naja darf man dann so reden und so
weiter und wenn man wenn man heute
schaut wie normal dass geworden ist und
auch der aufstieg der afg und so weiter
das sind ja dann schon zehn jahre in dem
sich doch viel geändert hat und nicht
unbedingt zum zum zum besseren grip 104
und testo wurden beide 1988 geboren
unter helmut kohl und erich honecker sie
wuchsen im norden auf in zetel und
stralsund dann zogen sie nach berlin und
gründeten zugezogen maskulin
ihre antwort auf den über blasen gangsta
rap der nullerjahre kann ich darf den
zugang zu mir nicht verlieren sonst
bleiben keine worte ich höre manchmal
türkischen und versucht sie irgendwie
auf deutsch zu übersetzen also sachen
damit ich sie halt für meine kunden
verwenden kann weil ich mag dieses in
der türkischen musik ist verläuft so
dass die so früh sterben in den songs
weil sie so sehr liebe zu haben und ich
liebe dieses gefühl dass wenn du so
etwas sterben würde mein leben doch
geschenkt doch ein stück davon
geheim
[Musik]
die müssen
diesen job
ich wollte den konflikt man meine eltern
halt thematisieren weil es gab eine zeit
wo ich meinen eltern wird nicht mehr
geredet haben und nicht ich selbst sein
konnte weil ich irgendwie zu hause immer
so ein bisschen andere mensch war als
draußen und ich wollte das nicht mehr
seit so wachsen die ersten
sonnenstrahlen
nein
[Musik]
zehn jahre lang war ich depressiv und er
ist jetzt so nach dem album kann ich
sagen so ich bin hab' davon so
herausgefunden
[Musik]
aber ich würde schon sagen ich hab's
auch faustdick hinter den ohren
weil sonst wäre ich nicht hier aber als
ich muss schon sagen als frauen der
branche ist es doch noch mal ganz anders
sich durchzukämpfen und so und seine
seine ziele zu verfolgen und dinge
umzusetzen
und man darf mich glaube ich nicht
unterschätzen
[Musik]
ja es gibt ja im rap das geflügelte wort
du kriegst den jungen aus dem ghetto
aber das geht so nicht aus ihm und bei
uns ist das mit der provinz hält das
ding halt so ich kann ich kann noch so
lange hier hier um rennen und so tun als
wenn ich jetzt so ein cooler großstädter
wäre in mir drin bin ich nach wie vor
ein provinzieller junger mann
ich glaube was irgendwie jungs so gemein
haben oder auf wachsende männer ist auf
jeden fall irgendwie das bedürfnis nach
so also härte irgendwie das ist mir halt
auch nicht nicht fremd möglichst hart
und nihilistisch und und eiskalt sein
das sind bei mir dann eher so klassische
web werte die da die da somit
eingesickert ich habe noch lesen und
schreiben gelernt mit der der fibel vom
vbb volk und wissen meine meine lehrer
meine meine erzieher und so weiter die
hatten alle noch noch ddr prägungen das
ist ja nicht von jetzt auf gleich so
abgelegt worden und was waren das für
werte die ddr menschenbilder und
männerbilder also man der muss
ordentlich anpacken können und so trauer
und angst hab ist jetzt muss jetzt nicht
unbedingt sein so dass irgendwie so ein
bisschen naja
ein zeichen gesetzt
die mal hakenkreuze waren feuerzeug
brand
und dann geht es ja weiter dann in den
90er jahren da war auf jeden fall bei
uns schon alles voll auch mit mit mit
neonazis das war halt die coolste junge
kultur überhaupt weil die eben in diesem
nachwende chaos also plötzlich werden
alle väter arbeitslos und die betriebe
machen dicht und die eltern die müssen
versuchen sich dann neu zurecht zu
finden und so und die hatten es eben
perfekt
ja weiß ich konnten sich die perfekt
irgendwie darin bewegen und durchsetzen
und für mich ich war ein kleines kleine
kleiner junge hat war das so eine
mischung aus furcht und und ja weiß
nicht ekel oder fun fun team gruselig
aber auch irgendwie eine form von
bewunderung dass die einfach ebenso
perfekt eigentlich an dieser umgebung
angepasst waren
und eben geisteskrank und hoch gedrehter
da weiß ich abgehört und parolen
geschrieben wurden umso besser schienen
die bei frauen anzukommen und bei ihren
kumpels
[Musik]
ich habe diese ganze konstrukt soja
männlichkeit und so weiter und so fort
das sind eigentlich erst sachen die ich
in den letzten 2 jahre irgendwie darüber
nachgedacht habe also als wir uns den
namen gegeben haben da habe ich noch gar
nicht so weit gedacht da war ich
eigentlich noch voll
auch auf dem trip und ich hatte da noch
ein sehr starkes bild von männlichkeit
und wie ich auch sein wollte und ich
habe das eigentlich dann so
perfektioniert dass ich nicht keine
ahnung und keine frau mehr gespürt habe
dass du abgespalten habe aber dadurch
eben dann panikattacken und depressionen
entwickelt habe
jetzt sind es schon zehn jahre die ich
in den abgrund starke aber wird es
wirklich schlimmer oder wird mein blick
noch klarer wird es wirklich dümmer oder
werde ich immer schlauer
fragt mich in zehn jahren noch mal
wissen wird genauer
[Musik]
weiter geht es mit rapper samy deluxe
und kölsch rocker wolfgang niedecken
unter strom
dabei biss
neuenfels
hallo
wer die ufer
dieser der bico pence
man fordere
euro
[Musik]
nun ruhen
wie oft er durch
[Musik]
stade
ja also ich war immer schon sehr sehr
sehnsüchtig was so reist betrifft wenn
wir hinten hin dass die südbrücke die
eisenbahnbrücke wenn wir als kind die
erlaubnis hatten drüben auf der pole
riese zu spielen das war für uns die
retter schlag wir dürfen dankbar und
haben wir richtungen richtung süden
geguckt das siebengebirge haben wir als
kleiner junge ist für die armen gehalten
und wir wussten ja hinter den alpen bis
italien kommt mehr und dann ist auch
schon afrika
wolfgang niedecken wurde 1951 geboren
konrad adenauer war seit zwei jahren
bundeskanzler
aufgewachsen in der zerbombten südstadt
lebt er auch heute in köln begründete er
[Musik]
es war ein kleines wunder plötzlich
verstand ganz deutschlands kann
deutschland dank die dürftig lernen dass
sich träume lohnt mitschülern die
fragten ob meine eltern aufbäumen wohnen
lehrerin die meinem bild namen als
beispiel wie man nicht mal hab ich
kopfweh am schrank als drohmittel mein
schicksal allergisch gegen autoritäten
kann so nicht leben
ich nehme da war er befehle von oben
gegen anfangs schien meiner hautfarbe
wie ein fluch ich werde beleidigt
ausgelacht und wurde diskriminiert
moment herauszufinden nicht mehr
privilegiert zivilisiert zivilisiert
kommen wir jetzt hochkultur
ich habe echt so oft sondern die
politischen diskussionen zu diesem
moment gab das dann wirklich so man hat
so eine weiße frau sich gemeinde manche
so können wir nicht aufhören immer mit
schwarz und weiß zu sagen ich fühle mich
total schlecht weil ich das jetzt noch
mal hören muss mit dem weißen nicht so
okay das ist jetzt das allerletzte dass
ich weiß mein leben lang hören muss dass
ich schwarz bin und jetzt wo ich in der
öffentlichen runde sind schöne weiße
frau sich an weiß angegriffen weil ich
das wort weiß benutzt und das für sie
ankommt ist weil sie denkt sie hat gar
keine farbe
weil sie ist ja einfach nur bringen
es wurde im deutschen herbst geboren
1977 unter kanzler helmut schmidt
aufgewachsen in hamburg lebt er heute
auch in berlin
ende der 90er wird er zur größe im
deutschen web
battle rap und botschaften
samy deluxe beherrscht beides
[Musik]
dass die trümmer nicht einfach nur
abenteuer empire spielplätze waren
sondern dass die woher kamen das wurde
einem dann so zwischen hat sich in der
einschulung und gymnasium oder an dass
das ist das war ja nicht immer so und
ich habe mich aber von da an wo mir das
bewusst wurde wirklich da immer sehr
sehr für interessiert nach wie vor
treibt mich dass um wie konnte das
ausgerechnet in so einer kulturnation
wie in deutschland passieren
[Musik]
den
lied kam vielleicht erreichen dass ich
andere leute auch mit dem thema
auseinandersetzt aber liegt kann ja
niemals mit dem global umlegen
kürzen
[Musik]
seltsam an
es ist ein deutliches stück als chor vom
stroh vom sturm ist sehr sehr konkret
das sind zwar meine ängste formuliert
aber die ängste brauchen keine
realistischen bilder kristallen hat war
noch zwischen wörgl und bosch da war
schon einiges und die hohe rote zeiger
und sowas aber rufen strom ist sehr
konkret die die ängste sind noch viel
konkreter geworden
seltsam
[Musik]
man ist als musiker so eine reflektion
fläche für die emotionen anderer leute
und oftmals ist das was man sagt dann
eben entweder einfach gut für für die
anderen betroffenen zu hören so dass das
jemand ausspricht und auch gut für die
leute die nicht betroffen sind aber sich
darüber gedanken machen über dieses
thema
[Musik]
gefragt wie ich und viele meiner nord zu
können
diesmal hat man die exekution einfach
gefühlt fast im livestream gesehen das
war ein paar stunden nachdem wir nach
dem essen gestorben ist hatten wir es
alle irgendwie auf unseren fans und
bildschirm und und auch der
gesichtsausdruck des polizisten so der
mit so einer sicherheit da saß und
dachte sie
was auch immer passiert die konsequenz
würden nicht bei mir enden
das war glaube ich das was das ist noch
schmerzhafter irgendwie gemacht hat so
dass dass der wert des lebens ist
einfach nicht anerkannt wird und das ist
da tatsächlich eine unterschiedliche
wertschätzung immer noch gibt in den
augen einzelner menschen und aber auch
systematisch vor geprägt
[Musik]
keine chance
viele meiner leute können nicht habe
meine geschichte ist so ich bin
aufgewachsen und brauner haut komplett
in der weißen welt so ich habe keinen
schwarzen mensch gekannt bevor ich ein
teenager wurde und als ich das erste mal
in so eine runde war mit schwarzem
leuten und gemerkt habe dass es gibt
auch positive attribute zu diesem ding
habe ich mir ein stolzer arbeitet und
auf den finde ich eben steuert also ich
bin stolz schwarzen sein gerade bei
schwarzen leuten kommt stolz und und
auch diese dieser community sind nicht
aus aus umwelt übernahme dingen sondern
aus ebene an einer extremen
unterdrückung oder comfort zone wenn man
endlich mal kurz sich nicht
rechtfertigen muss und nicht denkt man
dass fehler mord und nicht denken man
muss irgendetwas erklären nicht sagt
nein das ist nicht cool wenn du mir
meine haare fast wenn du das gehört
eine minderheit anzugehören schafft ein
drittes auge für mich fremd lecker bin
zu hause kommen sagt einer black lifes
männer sagt seiner wildlife männer das
hat nie jemand bezweifelt spricht da der
zeitgeist etwa deshalb sage ich
integration ist eine illusion denn in
der minderheits debatte fordert die
mehrheit inklusion wird die perfekte
gesellschaft wo an ich glaube dafür bin
ich falsch aufgestanden heute morgen
mich habe ich habe mich noch nie welche
die humanität heute für so positives
plädoyer jeder so wie er pokert
ich kann ich kann nicht kann nicht
rutschen
ich mache den vorteil aus sie dem
vorurteil aus jedem vorurteil kam durch
viele verschlossene türen und dann meine
offenheit er mit ignoranz falsche
betroffenheit gerade weil ich das
schwarze schaf war brachte ich licht in
die dunkelheit und nicht weit
ich mache mir nicht beliebt in dem ich
salz in die wunden streut von schlauen
feinden mehr gelernt als von einem
dummen freund privilegiert revidiert
jetzt kommen frank spilker von der band
die sterne und liedermacherin sarah
lesch
[Musik]
ach herbst endlich kommst du an gefegt
wie heilsam wenn alles sich wieder
bewegt schenks gleichmut milch und kakao
und kekse und kürbis kartoffeln und
hörspiele noch regen schon kaufen und
lebenslang lernen wie man mit dem herzen
für sie hier ich mir werde ich zu hause
bin und wie kriegt man was man begehrt
jedes gar nicht so dass ich jetzt
jemandem was erzähle was ich weiß und
der nicht sondern ich sehe mich eher wie
ein filter so also ich erlebe menschen
ich begegne menschen nicht filtere was
ich so spür und deswegen sage ich auch
liedermacherin so gern oder mag das wort
weil es ist wie ein hutmacher oder wie
einst schumacher oder es ist einfach so
wie jemand der so seine aufgabe hat im
kollektiv
sarah lesch wurde 1986 geboren da war
erich honecker staatsratsvorsitzender
von altenburg ging es ins schwabenland
2015 zog sie nach leipzig und wurde
hauptberuflich liedermacherin ihre songs
und texte preisgekrönt
die man alle erst und er zu mir und
wollten auch nur meine personalien
wann ich wo gewesen wäre und
pafl
nach zwei stunden in der zelle dachte
ich
da waren andere männer die werte waren
länger und ich wünschte ich wäre in
italien
nach der neuen deutschen welle gab es
natürlich die phase wo man sagen wir so
um 84 85 rom wollte niemand irgendwas
auf deutsche texte das hören weil man
sehr viel schlechter erfahrungen vorher
hatte mit ja so flitzt bieten aus dem
deutschen schlager business die dann
dachten sie können auch mal wave machen
also ich brauch jetzt keine namen
passiert hatte das war und mobiler
komplett satt und konnte diesen diesen
schwachsinn noch nicht mehr hören es gab
viele musiktheoretiker die gesagt haben
es geht gar nicht überhaupt auf deutsch
wegen referenz zum nationalsozialismus
und so weiter diese diskussion am
stattgefunden haben auch zurecht
stattgefunden und waren wichtig
[Musik]
noch einmal
freund
[Musik]
placke
1000 leute scheinen auf deutsche texte
wohin finde ich das café erstmal gut
warum weil es so weil es eigentlich eher
ist das anders gepolt wird ganz einfach
also was gebrüllt wird ist ich bin stolz
ein deutscher zu sein
frank später wurde 1966 geboren
da war ludwig erhard bundeskanzler
aufgewachsenen ostwestfalen gründete er
anfang der 90er jahre in hamburg seine
band die sterne
die hamburger schule waren aller munde
und versprach intelligente musik aus
deutschland
[Musik]
wo leute meine sprache sprechen
da bin ich zu
[Musik]
blühende landschaft aus leeren
versprechen sind trostlos unserem
vertraut ich glaube ich habe mich immer
schon zerrissen gefühlt zwischen allen
orten also ich bin an meine heimat ist
eigentlich dieses vielfältige diesen
große land und sie nachts am tresen
heimlich und auch zulauf über dreckige
witze lacht
mopo sie mit selbst im camp stellen
witzen und spuck gipfel zu machen
ich empfinde zum beispiel den
unterschied ist dass der austria
durchaus emanzipierter waren also dass
die frauen da sehr stark waren sie dass
die kinderbetreuung gesichert war ja und
das war dort im westen schon noch anders
irgendwie ein bisschen und heute weiß
ich dass meine mutter und die hat vor
zeit im krankenhaus gearbeitet war
alleinerziehend und es war für die die
hölle die wurde also nur angefeindet
also eine mutter die ihr kind in die
krippe steigt oder in den hort die kann
ja ihr kind nicht lieben wie kann eine
frau nur arbeiten und gleichzeitig und
ehrlich gesagt ich habe das gleiche
erfahren als ich mutter wurde mit 810
dann im westen leben im bezirk
erzieherberuf dass die immer noch zu
sprechen
als ich dann wieder zurückkamen den
osten jetzt bin ich an leipzig und dass
ich mit meinem sohn hier alleinerziehend
hingezogen bin standen sofort drei
menschen bei mir vor der tür die gesagt
haben was namen gehört her zieht jemand
alleine mit kind um
ich trage immer kurz die matratze hoch
und zack war das zeug in der bude und da
hab ich gedacht das ist der osten
das ist der osten und dass das finde ich
das feierlich schon echt ganz schön doll
das muss ich wirklich sagen jetzt für
mich echt schön ist noch ein anderes
gefühl von rudel hier
der ganze
wir schaffen das nur gemeinsam der
einsamkeit zum trotz
ich glaube dass es total hilft wenn man
wirklich echt den menschen begegnet und
daraus entstand dann erst eigentlich der
titel zum für die platte der einsamkeit
zum trotz in dem es ja um meine heimat
geht um auch so ein bekenntnis zu den
menschen mit denen ich aufgewachsen bin
von denen ich mich sehr lange abgrenzen
wollte auch ein bisschen und dieses
gefühl so ein kind des ostens aber auch
des westens zu sein und derzeit jetzt
also wie erlebe ich unser land wie
erlebe ich das eigentlich das viel
gerade gesprochen wird darüber was
deutsch sein bedeutet ja was was
bedeutet es denn und und wir haben ja
alle so angst dass uns irgendwas
weggenommen wird wenn irgendwas dazu
kommt
wer egal wo man geboren werden
oder als was
mann/frau frau man will oder kann
[Musik]
wählen waren so mag geht keinen was an
das ist der idealzustand für mich das
ist wurscht dass das herkunft egal dass
also ich finde ideale denen man sich
verpflichtet für werte so das ist
entscheidend was sich entscheidend ist
wo man geboren ist und ja oder mann oder
frau oder schwarz oder weiß integriert
euch doch selbst passt euch doch
[Musik]
wieder lieder singen
vielleicht auch mal feiern
so kann die aber
wenigstens aus
wir kennen wieder vor wir können wieder
vor wir wären am start wieder vor
wir würden lieber will
vielleicht auch mal feiern
die arbeit
wenigstens aus dem haus
die cam wieder vor
[Musik]
kennen wir doch
jetzt sagen könnten es wäre egal worum
angeboren oder als was die songs wo es
und was geht dies über den leuten immer
blieben natürlich grauenhaft nicht als
rockmusiker vernünftig zu vernunft
aufrufe ist ja ist ja im bildschirm es
ist immer besser so für die liebe zu
gehen und für das offen sein anstatt für
die angst und sich für die liebe zu
entscheiden ist finde ich immer
schwieriger als für die angst
[Musik]